apparently I'm a sucker for punishment
so welcome to day 2 of our 5 day
kids bedroom makeover
quick reminder of where we started
and since I saw you last my husband has
plastered and sanded these walls
so now I can prep and prime
and as somebody in the thick of a whole house renovation
I'm well aware that the most painful part of
the process is prepping for paint
but in every room I use this Dulux 1-step prep which is a primer
sealer and undercoat all in one
and it’s anti-mould which in my very damp
67 year old house I need
I will say it's pretty thick
pretty viscous kind of a bitch to get on
respectfully
but for the time that you save and the finish you get it's worth it
so the brief at this point of the project was just to get this stuff
literally everywhere and that was day two done
on day three we came back and it was time
to put some colour back in the space
and this is usually where I get my motivation back
because I can start to see my vision coming to life
so quick backstory but my first born is about to turn 12 which is crazy
and this bedroom is his birthday present
and he currently has no idea what we're doing in here
he did pick his bedding which helped us
with colour and he asked for panelling
but aside from that he's totally in the dark
I don't know about you but whenever I look at a project
I always gaslight myself into believing
it's gonna be less work than it actually is
and when it comes time you're like
wow fk
there really is a lot to do in here isn’t there
so I ended up painting that panelling three times
and what I think is the perfect shade of green
that's Te Horo by Dulux
My husband did the ceiling and I did the windows
which are always a nightmare
and now I'm doing the second coat of the best creaming neutral I've ever met
this is half glinks gully by Dulux
and I'm using it right throughout my house
and that is days 2 and 3 done
but there are still so much to do
so come back for the update